in louisville hundreds of people
protested for a third straight night
demanding justice for brianna taylor
one of the officers involved in the
botched raid was charged in the shooting
but the charge is not directly tied to
killing taylor
police fired flashbangs to break up
crowds on friday evening
several people were arrested for being
out past the city's 9 p.m curfew
other protests took part in cities
across the country
and as adriana diaz reports protesters
young and old
say they will remain on the streets
until someone is held accountable
for briana taylor's death
late friday mary williams who's in her
70s
marched with a walker you're still
making such an effort to be here
yeah i've been doing this all my life
and this is far cheerful earlier crowds
demanded this
release the transcript release
the transcript family attorney ben crump
accused
kentucky attorney general daniel cameron
of swaying the grand jury
he demands that cameron who was tasked
with impartially presenting evidence to
the grand jury
make that evidence public release the
transcript
so we can have transparency the attorney
general's office told cbs news
everyone is entitled to their opinion
but prosecutors and grand jury members
are bound by the facts
and by the law the grand jury concluded
that the only
criminal acts that night were for the
shots that hit a neighbor's apartment
and that police acted in legal
self-defense because taylor's boyfriend
fearing a home invasion fired first
injuring an officer
taylor's boyfriend fired once police
returned more than 30 rounds
tamika mallory who leads the activist
group until freedom
and works closely with taylor's mother
said this
about the attorney general they didn't
even mention her daughter's name
in the damn indictment process in this
grand jury hearing
come on how dare you karis jefferson who
didn't know
taylor took her children to see the
speeches it's a little heavy for
children but i think
that they need to see it they need to
know what's going on so they can be
the best that they can be so they can be
a part of the change for the future
how do you feel i'm hurt
i'm really hurting thank you protesters
also registered voters friday
you're calling for people to go to the
polls so that policies can be changed
what is the number one policy that you
think
can change things george floyd justice
and police and accountability act as it
speaks to the systematic reform
that we need in policing all across
america
to prevent future brianna taylors to
prevent future george floyd's
to prevent future jacob blake jrs to
prevent future pamela turners
police reform bill named for george
floyd would ban no knock warrants which
was used here in the case of brianna
taylor
it would also raise the standard for
what justifies use of force
that bill is currently held up in
congress as for whether the state
attorney general
daniel cameron will release the evidence
presented to the grand jury
he said previously that he would revisit
that matter after the fbi concludes
its investigation jeff okay adriana
thank you